I can't wait to sweat it out with these
guys let's get some happy tears and
we'll probably gonna put no blood to it
things get wild when Edie crashes Joe
and Jenna's Dancing with the Stars
rehearsal with their trio edition George
very exciting week is bachelor nation
meets Dancing with the Stars but I heard
that this is literally the first time
you guys are meeting with Jordan just
nothing yeah that's a great I know the
motivated to dedicate to what they're
doing and well you know I'm not
professional dancer so I've got
structured choreography experience I'm
not gonna call it dance but I can't like
move too sexy for my shirt good job
Jordan too sexy for my shirt too sexy
arms of charm and close your feet salsa
to the side I'm sexy form line that was
perfect
dancing - I'm too sexy do you feel like
you have your hands full of these - no
I'm excited yeah I think that their
energy this week we're really gonna see
show because you have George's
performance is probably gonna force me
to come out of my shell in their choice
like I have no choice yeah I don't know
how I'm gonna feel after but that's what
you're gonna feel great we paint the
boar with ten's arms quick quick punch
[Applause]
hold to punch and five six close your
feet stop Jordan for you why was this
the right now you know you gotta show
people that the best thing to do
whenever you're going through a rough
time is join your friends and try it out
there and to move bottle walking there
might be another one are you gonna be
paying homage at all to bachelor nation
like roses red I don't think people are
knowing that expect what we're gonna be
doing okay
I think everyone thinks we're gonna be
models no no no I wanted to do something
that just made these two shines well the
ladies are gonna go crazy
yeah if you like if you like a nice
sassy salsa this is okay very important
question though are we gonna get the
gold boxer-briefs I don't know about and
get this Friday was the first time
Jordan started learning the dance for
Monday's bake show do you feel pressure
because it's Friday
and you guys are dancing on Monday I
feel pressured every day so it really
it's all about it's not about dancing
it's not moving and being suave and
having confidence and just putting that
best for Cory look it's not even about
being with dance it's about being sexy
fun and what are you doing you're better
so I'm keeping it
what do you mean
he was briefing one thing's for sure
what began as a bromance on bachelor in
paradise is still going strong on
Dancing with the Stars honestly so I
mean I talked to Joe very frequently I
know he's been busy lately I've been
busy but we always make some time
I cannot hop on a phone call with this
guy and not feel like I can relate to
him where you can relate to me and we
just end up dying laughing on the phone
now I like Joe I gotta go I'm peeing
myself right now I gotta go
no we're just die laughing I love this
guy he's a great easy very pregnant
people ask who's your best friend even
that franchise yeah it's Joe absolutely
you heard it here first
[Music]